one of president Trump's most supportive
witnesses in the impeachment inquiry has
changed his testimony to confirm a quid
pro quo with Ukraine the ambassador to
the European Union Gordon Sunland now
tells lawmakers that the Trump
administration held up military aid as
it pushed Ukraine's government to
investigate - investigate Democrats
including the Biden family Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill Nancy just how
significant is this reversal well
Anthony it means that ambassador Sandlin
has now become at least the fifth
witness in this probe to testify to some
sort of quid pro quo he amended his
earlier testimony in which he had
downplayed his own role after several
other witnesses contradicted him it's
never too late to do the right thing
Democrats applauded Sunland for amending
his testimony to say that he does now
recall telling a Ukrainian official that
aid would likely not occur until Ukraine
provided a public Anti Corruption
statement specifically reopening the
investigation into burr yzma the energy
company that employed the son of mr.
Trump's campaign rival Joe Biden the
State Department was being politicized
by the president and essentially being
turned into an instrument of his
reelection campaign even in his original
testimony somnolent told lawmakers that
the pressure campaign led by the
president's lawyer Rudy Giuliani kept
getting more insidious as time went on
hardly the exoneration the White House
and Republicans had claimed this is what
they said back then he was very clear no
quid pro quo multiple times go look at
what Gordon Sandlin said today and it is
in his testimony now Republicans are
downplaying sound let's roll you're
wanting to focus on ambassador Sandlin
instead of focusing on ambassador
Volcker who was the Ukrainian envoy but
Volcker whose testimony was released -
described the president's demand for
dirt on Biden as extremely unfortunate
for our policy with Ukraine still Senate
Leader Mitch McConnell suggested that
wasn't enough -
impeachment to work today I don't think
there's any question it would not lead
to a removal all signs point to public
hearings starting sometime next week and
lasting up until Thanksgiving break that
would set up Democrats hope a vote on
actual articles of impeachment some time
before primary season officially gets
underway early next year
Gail all right Nancy thank you